c'est ma tante mon tapis de sol un
format moustiques
oui elisa et hugo sont deux néophytes du
cyclotourisme une façon de voyager dont
la popularité est en hausse chez nous
l'achalandage augmenter considérablement
sur les réseaux cyclables en ville
notamment sa le doublé dans bien des cas
au québec cette année
et c'est vrai ou c'est en région est ce
que le matin quand tu pars tu elisa une
étudiante originaire de france revient
de sa toute première excursion je suis
partie de montréal je suis remonté
jusqu'à trois rivières québec
j'ai remonté charlevoix par la route du
fleuve puis je suis parti dans le
saguenay donc par leur quart d'heure sur
l'art et noir fait le tour du lac saint
jean hugo lui s'apprête à vivre son
baptême du tourisme sur deux roues dans
quelques semaines le port de rosemont
petite patrie et je me donne 14 jours
précisément pour me rendre minimum à
carleton sur mer maximum à percer j'ai
acheté deux sacs à sharjah il a mis près
de deux mois pour acheter un bon vélo
usagé et tout l'équipement nécessaire au
coût d'environ 1500 $ ça me coûte quand
même beaucoup moins cher mais c'est un
trait de longue haleine de patience de
chercher à chaque jour sur marketplace
kg si hugo a bien pris soin de tout
planifier et lisa elle est partie sur un
coup de tête avec un simple vélo de
ville usagers également et un équipement
rudimentaire tout ça pour moins de 1000
$ je gardais sur google maps j'ai dit ça
fait peu près 500 km je dise c'est pas
impossible d'en bas et je me suis lancée
puis j'ai tout acheté en cinq ou six
jours
mais à part quelques crevaisons qu'elle
a apprise à réparer elle-même la jeune
femme de toulouse a été ravie par les
nombreuses rencontres faites en chemin
les gens ont vraiment été très très
accueillants ya pas une seule fois où ça
que je me suis retrouvé à la rue pour
dormir j'ai jamais demandé c'est
toujours les gens qui sont venus et qui
m'ont dit t'as quelque part où dormir ce
soir je disais je vais encore continuer
pm10 mais non grèce puis j'ai dormi dans
des étapes g/t or j'ai dormi dans des
chambres dans des jardins j'espère
vraiment pour une première expérience a
vraiment été elle fait de son côté hugo
à l'intention d'utiliser le service en
ligne world charge pour des séjours chez
l'habitant
ça c'est pratique pour avoir des
endroits parfois ou couché quinquin il
ya pas d'autres options plus en plus ça
permet de rencontrer les gens puis c'est
très convivial
évidemment ce type de voyage ne plaît
pas à tous d'autres préféreront une
excursion organisée et que leurs bagages
soit transporté d'une auberge à l'autre
l'important avant de partir et de se
poser certaines questions parce que j'ai
envie de partir faire des longues
distances dormir en paix où est ce que
j'ai envie de me la couler un peu plus
dos
ensuite de quoi suis-je capable est ce
que moi je suis capable de rouler 150
100 km par jour ou si 30 km par jour
sera amplement suffisant
et pour se donner des idées de trajet le
guide de la route verte qui s'étend sur
5300 km partout dans la province et
disponible en ligne et en version papier
les curieux peuvent aussi consulter les
diverses pages facebook de cyclotourisme
au québec michel chabot radio canada
montréal